OK.
Along the same lines, I'm getting martial
law questions and they relate not just to
coronavirus but to the election.
And the question is, David, will Donald Trump
declare martial law and suspend the election
due to Corona virus?
We already talked about this a little bit
earlier this week when we got a voicemail.
So martial law is when military control is
placed over civilian functions of government.
So this would be if there's an emergency,
a major disaster, terrorist attack in an occupied
territory, et cetera.
It is very complicated legal territory when
it comes to things that require that that
are sort of bound by the law.
The election date and when electors need to
formally cast their ballots for the candidate
that won on election day is prescribed in
the Constitution.
And so you would need Congress to say something
about the election being moved to a different
day this year.
December 14th is when the electors are supposed
to vote.
If Massachusetts votes for Biden, the electors
on December 14th need to go and say Massachusetts
casts our electors for Joe Biden at then the
delegate counting convention, whatever, to
go beyond December 14.
With that, it would take an act of Congress
or something extraordinary.
Now, where it starts to get dicey is if you
have martial law and civilian courts are closed,
imagine that there is such a lockdown that
martial law is put in place.
And it's not just restaurants and public transit
that are shut down.
Civilian court courts are closed.
Martial law could dictate that military courts
start to get involved in adjudicating some
of these things.
It's conceivable that moving the election
beyond when December 14th would be the date
where the electors vote up could end up going
to courts if the civilian courts are down.
It could conceivably go to a military court.
This is insanely unlikely.
Now, I want to remind folks who like the idea
of martial law to keep Trump in power.
Number one, either way, even if there's no
election, Donald Trump's term constitutionally
ends on January 20, 2021.
At that point.
Again, it's contested exactly the logistics,
but the speaker of the House would become
president of the United States.
That is scheduled to be Nancy Pelosi.
That's number one.
And so I don't know that from this are really
well served by focusing on this.
Number two, typically when martial law is
declared, guns are confiscated.
OK.
Again, I don't know that the pro-Trump gun
nuts are going to be thrilled if the martial
law they believe might keep Trump in is also
used as a justification to start confiscating
their guns.
It will probably get ugly.
Checkpoints typically get set up in cities.
It's all very, very bad.
So let's all not be hoping for that, regardless
of whether it might keep Trump in office an
extra month or something.
It's unlikely to do that.
And these are exactly the type of questions
that really expose the degree of uncertainty
and fear that is going on.
And I sympathize with that.
But let's all work together here.
Think not just of yourself, but of other people,
do what the experts are asking you to do.
And hopefully we can start to turn this curve,
find that inflection point and turn things
in the right direction so we can have an election
on schedule, we can have a peaceful transfer
of power if that is what the voters decide.